okay
so
after years and years of watching
youtube videos people they love
people that you don't so much love
just having it take over your entire
life i mean i don't even watch
television anymore i literally youtube
don't watch tv at all how do you start
your very own one
and that's a very hard question what
most of us do is we look at youtube
videos how to successfully get started
on youtube look at tutorials we read
about it make sure you have good
lighting make sure you have a camera
make sure you have good editing
techniques
and most of us don't even get around to
making that first video
because we're too nervous or too awkward
so hi
my name name's yasmin also known as
jagman by my friends i am a person
living in a shared house which is pretty
creepy because they could be listening
right now and that's embarrassing i've
just recently moved to london which is
quite scary i used to live in plymouth
and that's like
it's not even that tiny
but compared to this it really is what
was i saying
yes so i'm a person and like you
why should you be me to
make a vlog or a gaming channel or
yeah unless you only have one hobby
which is fair enough you can have one of
it i have a lot of hobbies i like
diys
games
abandoned buildings
exploring just
general
[ __ ] so [ __ ] it i'm just gonna make
videos of whatever
when i feel like it where i feel like it
and this is very awkward
because i'm talking to a camera
but i'm sure i'll get over that
suppose it's hard so i've never made a
video before
you've never made a video before
and the sunlight is just coming down not
for very much longer because i have a
big ass building from my window
it's quite intimidating i don't even
have a right stand so i've just got
this
this is my stand yeah all very
professional stuff
just be yourself
and that
will make everything okay it's what i've
heard
so
yeah
how do you end the video
say goodbye
oh yeah i suppose i'll just see what
happens
bye
i want to do this because i'm bored
i don't know don't i have no friends
i probably shouldn't tell
she's like man is big no won't find me